this program is brought to you by Emory
University
I just so you are proactive about me and
that's where advocacy begins it begins
with you no one will know what's going
on with you unless you open your mouth
and say it may not like it it may not
like being label I've heard that before
people say that they don't want to be
labeled will forget your label don't
worry about yourself consider it
something that you would do for someone
else if we don't talk about what's going
on thus no one will know that these
things are going on with us and no one
can help us that's the way that you ever
consider ginz you've got to open your
mouth and speak up and one of the things
that really gets my goat is that what
people said we don't have a national
facing we need somebody to be the voice
of lupus i'm like okay i can give you
patience on top of patients whose voice
is powerful enough to tell their own
stories so I don't need somebody that's
a face that's recognizable I just need
you to listen to the everyday patient
that lives with this disease and let
them tell their stories and so that's
why we can take it from a whisper to a
shout because there's enough people out
here that are sick and tired of people
saying you know what we don't know what
lupus is so let's use our voice and
let's do something we advocate for
ourselves because who else is going to
do it and we do this for the people that
can't get out of it that are going to
depression that are going through so
much joints fatigue and pain that they
do feel like they give it they're giving
up or they're always asking the
questions why me so we do these kinds of
stories and get the involvement of
patients so that people that cannot use
their voice where that boys
you
the preceding program is
copyrighted by Emory University